il y a une grosse nouveauté sur les
iPhone pro capteur de 48 mégapixels puis
très longtemps on a des capteurs de 12
mégapixels sur tous les iPhones que ce
soit sur les modèles normaux sur les
modèles professionnels cette année sur
les iPhone 14 pro et 14 pro max on va
retrouver un capteur de 48 mégapixels 4
fois plus de pixel que ce qu'on avait
sur les générations précédentes
qu'est-ce que ça vient apporter beaucoup
plus de détails dans l'image et puis
surtout aux technologique 4 pixels en un
on prend quatre gros pixels on en fait
un seul et même pixel ça permet de
capter plus de lumière et d'améliorer
significativement les photos de nuit des
images plus nettes des photos plus
lumineuses voilà la promesse que nous
fait Apple sur ces modèles
professionnels je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez est-ce que ça pourrait vous
tenter oui ou non dites-le-moi en bas
dans les commentaires et pour tout
savoir de la cutec je vous invite à
venir vous abonner